[Music]
as vladimir putin's forces continue to
wage war in ukraine as the war in
ukraine rages on civilian casualties are
mounting there has been no let up in the
fighting
the pressure is building in
russia putin's having to lie about the
campaign at home and he's paranoid about
the failure
with further escalation on the cards
and peace talks so far going nowhere
how could this war end
[Music]
there's an astonishing drone video of
russian columns in streets in an urban
area east of kiev and it's it's
astonishing because it shows you how the
russians are not learning sending these
armored forces in without infantry
screening the armor around them to push
back other forces without aerial
protection and air cover those mistakes
signify not just ukrainian
resourcefulness and ingenuity but i
think also deep russian dysfunction in
failures even on russian state
television
they're now talking about how they got
bogged down the mothers the wives the
girlfriends the sisters
brothers etc
are starting to get notices of their uh
of their dear ones dead
and and getting you know watching a war
on the sofa uh on television is one
thing but actually having people die in
this conflict it's quite another which
is why putin cannot actually call for
general mobilization at least not yet uh
he never prepared people for this war
he called it a special military
operation it was supposed to be uh done
within presumably a few days but putin
is a man who can never ever accept his
mistake he can never accept his error
because actually that would be not just
the laws of power at this point i think
it would be much worse than that and uh
he will go on because it's now his life
is attached uh to this conflict
[Music]
he's having to lie about the campaign at
home and he's paranoid about the failure
and the huge miscalculation he's made
that failure what that does to his power
base so he's worried the people around
him will be trying to blame each other
they'll be trying to find scapegoats
he'll be paranoid and anxious there are
reports that two very senior members of
the fsb which is russia's domestic
security service the main successor to
the kgb have been placed under house
arrest and these two individuals
um uh were both involved closely in
planning for the invasion so that gives
you a sense of uh the sort of mood in
moscow in the sense of anxiety if you
think of the mechanism of a coup
um
what what is it how does this come about
well it comes about when
some people who are close to power
think that their time is up and they
think that someone is about to move
against them
and that if they don't act first they'll
end up in jail or dead
and so that's why this is such an
unstable moment because the moment at
which blame is being cast is the moment
which everybody's looking to see whether
they're the ones who are going to end up
carrying the can for this disaster and
if they if they're convinced they are
then that's when they move and they try
and move before they're arrested so
this erect this house arrest it is like
the starting pistol firing and we'll see
how it unfolds
[Music]
there's two sorts of risks one of them
is that the war going badly compels
vladimir putin to use something like
chemical weapons
and that creates intense pressures on
western governments to intervene and of
course when the syrian regime used
chemical weapons in 2018 the us uk and
france conducted airstrikes against them
that won't happen in this case it won't
happen and i think although the no-fly
zone debate will revive i think
ultimately there will be no appetite for
the biden administration or in europe to
seriously contemplate shooting down
russian planes or blowing up russian air
defense systems
however there are other sorts of
interventions we could see so for
example could we see a debate over
whether nato should send uh chemical
biological radiological unit protective
units to a site where chemical weapons
have been used i ultimately think any
combat forces on ukrainian soil in a way
that may drag us into confrontation is
still a very very low probability
outcome but the pressures for that
outcome will grow in the aftermath of
such an atrocity but the second
possibility even without the use of
chemical weapons is a scenario in which
vladimir putin decides that western arms
supplies are causing him too many
problems that this is a this represents
western intervention and that he
attempts to strike a arms depot in
poland or simply strike a arms convoy
moving into ukraine in the western side
of that country
those sorts of things could easily
involve escalation to a nato-russia
conventional clash and then that could
spiral into russian nuclear use that
would create pressures for western
nuclear use we shouldn't exaggerate
those risks i think with the west
western governments are absolutely keen
to stay out of this conflict directly
but nor should we be complacent about
those risks because they they do exist
uh and these are these are the certainly
the highest prospect of uh war between
russia and the west we have seen since
the 1980s if not before
[Music]
my best case scenario is that this does
not actually escalate into the use of
chemical or nuclear weapons of mass
destructions
so whatever the peace settlement is my
uh absolutely best hope is that uh would
come out and it will not come out well
nobody will come out of well uh of this
any time soon i don't think but
minimizing and not letting it into a
stage of complete catastrophe would be
my best
hope at the moment you know ukrainian
morale self-belief
is hugely important in their effort
to counter russian attacks
and one way to destroy morale i think
putin's hoping for in an old way it goes
back to the 19th century when russian
forces used artillery against cities
is to try and kill civilians and to
make people miserable and i think if you
do that you present um zinski with the
the ukrainian president with a decision
which is
do do you go for peace do you settle in
some way with russia in order to spare
your people
and by killing people now in
indiscriminate ways and in large volumes
you present zelensky with that very
difficult choice
for me the best outcome is
a negotiated settlement
that leaves um the zelinski government
in place
in which zelensky willingly
makes
some agreements such as recognizing
russia's hold on crimea
and says he's not going to join nato but
he willingly does it this is not
something that's imposed on him
and then
that
russian forces withdraw
including from the all the areas they've
occupied
and i think that has
that's
that has two advantages
one is
that the ukrainians themselves having
forged a nation in this crisis would
then be free to go their way and i think
their way leads towards the west
and the second point is that i don't
think a russian leader especially not
vladimir putin if they do that will
invade
again thank you for watching for all our
coverage on the war in ukraine please
click on the link and don't forget to
subscribe